be where I've come from the future to
warn you that the plague will soon wipe
out all originality on basic cable I
explain everything on this week's
episode of angry nerd so the 1995 sci-fi
movie 12 monkeys is mutating into a
series on the sci-fi channel affiliation
now what's the human race to get me wet
down by the lake I asked you what you
thought of this and the kindest comment
was that it looked like a dragged-out
version of the movie but with worse
actors oh touche ignacio this new show
worries me not because terry gilliam's
time-travel flick is sacrosanct frankly
I think Gilliam's a heretic for turning
the flawless 1962 film la jetée into 12
monkeys in the first place 12 monkeys is
yet another time slot filled by a lazy
concept flip around the dial tonight
dials you'll see brand extensions
reboots and spin-offs of old public
domain stories and 12 monkeys is just
the tip of the derivative burg there are
pilots in development for shows based on
movies like westworld big rush hour
scream marley and me and real genius Oh
Lazlo would be furious okay okay I'll
admit the TV adaptations of the movies
Fargo and alienation and Buffy worked
well but these new do-overs are far more
likely to turn out like oh anger
management see we remember the rare
successes like mash
forget the all-too-common dreck like the
blessedly short-lived series Ferris
Bueller
this is television this is real wouldn't
the money sunk into licensing these old
properties be better spent on trying to
create you know something new I'm here
to tell you that the media industry
human centipede has officially begun
eating its own tail hey come to think of
it why has no one made a series out of
human centipede time to call my agent
and set up a backdoor pilot Saturday
morning cartoons came to an end last
fall but their spirit now seems to be
inhabiting primetime I mean think about
it there were cartoons based on Free
Willy Ghostbusters beetlejuice karate
kid Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
back to the future Beethoven Mighty
Ducks the mask Ace Ventura men in black
teen wolf what TV show would you like to
see turned into a movie let me know in
the comments and subscribe to the wire
channel and be sure to watch it I tiny
versions of me stay back mini
doppelgangers oh oh wait those are just
my other videos watch them all they're
great are they looking at me right now
I'm afraid to turn my head